An alternative, is to perform address lookups, using a
data structure called a try. In a try, prefixes
are spelled out by following a path from the
root. And to find the best prefix, we simply spell
out the address in the try. For example, let's
suppose we had the following table. Such a lookup
table has entries of varying lengths. Let's see how
this might be encoded in a try. In a try,
spelling out the bit one always takes us to the right, and spelling out the bit
zero always takes us to the left. So to insert one one one star, we'd basically
start here. One. One. One. And then we
insert P1, and then we repeat this process.
One, zero, star results in P2. One, zero,
one, zero, results in P3. And one, zero,
one, zero, one results in P4. If we
want to insert one, one, one, zero, insertion is
easy. We can simply insert P5 as such.
Look ups are easy, so for example let's suppose
we want to look up 10111. Well all we have to do, is spell this out in the try.
So we can follow 1-0-1 and now, we see that there's no entry for 1011.
So, we use the entry of the last node in the tree that we traverse, that has
an entry in this case P2. Now this
structure here is what's called a single bit try.
Single bit trys are very efficient. Not that
every note in this try exists due to one
of the five folding table entries that we've
inserted in the try. So, a single bit try
is a very efficient use of memory. Updates are
also very simple. We saw how easy it was,
to insert the entry for P5. And fortunately, the
main problem is the number of memory accesses that
are required to perform a lookup. For 32 bit
address, we can see, that looking up the address
in a single bit trie, might require 32 look
ups, in the worst case. One for each bit.
So it's each bit in the address requires, one traversal in the trie, or one
memory look up. So this could be very bad. At worst, 32 accesses in the
worst case. To put this in perspective,
an OC48 requires a 160 nanosecond lookup, or
simply 4 memory accesses. So 32 accesses, is
far too many, especially for high speed links.